that tastes exactly like Captain Crunch
with it does hey Dad I'm actually
surprised laser accurate honey hi my
name is Christian I'm a BuzzFeed
producer out in New York I used to be a
Starbucks barista I know there's a full
secret menu of frappuccinos it tastes a
lot like popular breakfast cereals so
all three odd Frappuccino requests now
these aren't officially Starbucks drinks
but they were developed by baristas so
they could emulate the exact taste of
these cereals so figured I would have
some of my co-workers try something I
love it you but like the colors a little
disconcerting is a little disconcerting
at least with the unicorn thing was like
exciting look right right it's so modern
stuff like off pink it looks kind of
like the color of the milk after you eat
the cereal so in that way I accept it
and I believe in it should we should we
try it yeah I'll let you go first
okay let's see here oh my god that's
actually so good I love it I guess if
someone asked me to describe what
Captain Crunch tastes like right I
wouldn't be able to say it but I know
that this tastes like heaven I mean if
this one actually really tastes like
Captain Crunch I'm actually surprised my
mind is blown yeah we're setting the bar
very high airy hypothesis is dead-on
[Music]
you're pulling out all my favorite
cereals yeah I'm not a Lucky Charms
person whatever it is about like the
marshmallows literally gives me goose
looks like I have chills right now and
when I was a kid I would literally take
the entire bag and I would only eat the
marshmallows should we try it I'm super
yeah I think we just have to try it
because I don't know for it
the last one blew us away so no no this
is very chocolatey are you sure I don't
think this is right
tastes like very you think I'm on me
like chocolate drink not quite yeah
chocolate milk definitely chocolate
drink do you whoo this is not Lucky
Charms
I think this frappuccinos fake news I'm
ready for the next one
[Music]
yeah probably one of the best serials of
all time
that's a hard agree for me it looks
really good
let's do it all right a hundred percent
spot Oh excellent
I am excited without even trying again
come on now that is so good
here's my issue right this has coffee in
it and it is ruining it for me they just
need to leave the coffee out of it so
everything about this one hit the mark
the look the flavor get this how much I
really like the Captain Crunch one but
the best one was definitely the cinnamon
toast yeah I think I think I'm in the on
the same team as that crunch ties we can
wear all day the Captain Crunch was like
so surprising like no way could a drink
taste like a tank run no idea that they
could do that some barista in a far-off
land probably it smoked eight bowls and
then they were like this they were like
what a great line of real rapper
cherries smoked table in a sense